un latté match à un latté au curcuma un
latté à la betterave des boissons
chaudes et colorées que l'on trouve de
plus en plus dans les cafés montréalais
ça peut faire d'étranges pour ceux qui
s'attendent un café que ce soit une
épice qui remplace le kafil qu'on voit
c'est ya beaucoup plus de bénéfices aux
compagnies innovantes beaucoup pour ses
prétendues zecca pour la saint loup qui
se développe comme un parallèle au café
ou même levêque
allo alors est-ce que je prends pas la
tête
dans ce petit café jh williams offre
maintenant ces alternatives au café
latté comme cela tu es à la betterave
une poudre de betteraves déshydraté et
diluée dans l'eau est mélangé à une
boisson végétale mou c'est pareil à un
café latté et au début on savait
préférence café mais de plus en plus on
penser à diversifier pire a ajouté
d'autres gammes de la saison
c'est juste un espoir aliments dans le
fond son succès sur l'espèce au plomb
linverse pour une base de match à
windows de betteraves c'est une
alternative facile soit le midi ou soit
le soir on cherche quelque chose qui a
peut-être un peu moins de café jason
aussi se spécialise dans ce type de
lattes et plus spécifiquement avec du
match à cette boisson japonaise
traditionnelle plus connus qui est faite
de feuilles de thé vert broyer mélangée
à du lait ou à une boisson végétale
nous on a vu que pourquoi pas adapté
parce qu'on fait le match on peut donner
même plus d'options comme le curcuma et
comme les betteraves qu'on boit ça ya
beaucoup plus de bénéfices qui donne
envie aux gens de le boire c'est sûr
parce que tout le monde vise sur la
santé toujours pour la santé on nous
propose aussi des lattes et au curcuma
ce que déguste aujourd'hui la
nutritionniste stéphanie côté ou des
particuliers ce n'est pas ce que
j'espère beaucoup plus dans les plats
que je mange pas missionnant plutôt que
je bois mais le goût ferry selon la
recette
l'équipe de maryse kim athena est allé
seul à travailler à l'élaboration de la
recette parfaite de lattes et au curcuma
elles ont préparé le mélange d'épicés
fait de poivre cardamome cannelle poudre
de noix de coco et curcuma
tout a été méticuleusement peser et noté
ce travail d'équipé a permis de créer un
produit instantanée de cette boisson
indiennes sont à tout décider exactement
qu'est ce qu'on veut la voir comme ratio
et c'est un mélange qu'on a envoyé à
notre partenaire de production au sri
lanka pour que tous soient mélangées
très très frais alors là je viens
d'appeler mes partenaires cha et maliki
sont sri lanka vient de faire toute la
tournée du pays sont vus nous nos
partenaires là bas qui font des récoltes
de curcuma de cannes algérie table c'est
une boisson traditionnelle ayurvédique
qui est conçu pour non seulement bon
pour le goût un réchauffeur brute au
sens mais aussi et très apaisant
plusieurs entreprises font des mélanges
pour faire ces boissons à la maison
chacune a sa version je suis un peu
comme un carry on dit que karim et on
change de région dans l'ain dans
différents pays
on y retrouve plein différents mélanges
c'est un peu comme ça de la tête curcuma
alors oui à le curcuma mais on peut y
ajouter le gingembre le clou de girofle
le goût mais c'est un goût inné qui fit
faut l'écouter pour la prends c'est quoi
ça goûte le curcuma et le document qu'on
la boive ou qu'on le mange le corps va
l'utiliser de la même façon donc souvent
quand on fait un latté avec du curcuma
il ya soit du groupe contre comme tu
peux même de poivre pour justement
favoriser l'absorption ce n'est en
pratique il n'ya pas d'étude qui
démontre qu'il ya des bienfaits pour la
santé de voir des la paix que ce soit à
base de curcuma à base de match a même
ou à base d'autres herbes et épices donc
vraiment voir ces boissons là parce
qu'on les a pris 6 mai pop en pensant
qu'on va se protéger du cancer
cependant toutes ces boissons
proviennent d'aliments qui contiennent
des antioxydants et on mise sur les
bienfaits de ces nutriments comme le
match à la betterave ou le curcuma mais
c'est un univers de saveurs à explorer
le great assez fatigué mais par exemple
le matin cet hiver donc été plutôt amer
tandis que la betterave trop sucrés
comme m la betterave justement parce que
le curcuma avec plus relevé c'est sûr
que durant l'hiver je pense que c'est
des goûts très recherchée ses dégoûts de
confort dre que le bienfait de ces
boissons là c'est vraiment les prendre
comme une boisson chaude de prendre un
moment probablement de le partager aussi
donc si c'est bien fait c'est peut-être
celui là de prendre
[Musique]